le château de Ternay n'ouvre que
rarement ses portes mais le cours Sainte
Clotilde d'une école tenue par une
congrégation dominicaine n'a pas hésité
à les ouvrir pour accueillir cette
exposition l'idée faire revivre le
dramaturge et cinéaste français Sacha
Guitry dans sa résidence secondaire il a
acquis la maison que vous voyez derrière
nous en 1937 jusqu'à sa mort il y a vécu
jusqu'à sa mort en 1957 dans le grand
salon au rez-de-chaussée vous pourrez
découvrir que Sacha Guitry était un
grand artiste trois pièces du château
ont été aménagés pour découvrir les
différents visages de Sacha Guitry d'un
côté cinéaste artiste mais aussi
comédien et réalisateur des tableaux des
photographies des dessins de sa main et
des manuscrits permettent de retracer la
vie de ce personnage au mille casquettes
des objets personnels de l'artiste prêté
par la Bibliothèque historique de la
Ville de Paris l'écrivain Yann Moix le
manuscrit français et même la société
Pathé un parcours animé par des pièces
de théâtre jouées par les élèves de
Première en spécialité histoire de l'art
de l'école
souvenirs auquel je tiens énormément les
12 élèves se sont préparés toute l'année
pour cette exposition on a préparé des
petits textes que l'on peut voir dans
les le livret de l'exposition donc sur
ces particularités de Sacha Guitry puis
pour préparer la l'exposition on a créé
donc tous les petits cartels
d'exposition avec les descriptifs à
chaque fois les visiteurs ont pu
profiter de l'espace extérieur
transformé à l'époque en zoo par Sacha
Guitry voir le parc que nous avions vu
seulement en photo nous sembler
indispensable pour voir ce que renfermer
cet écrin derrière les grands murs et
nous avons été impressionnés par la
beauté de l'exposition prochaine porte
ouverte du château les journées du
patrimoine en septembre prochain